some of the characters who have popped
up in Disney's mandalorian are simply
callbacks to early Star Wars movies some
on the other hand answer decades-old
questions while others just bring up
more questions on the show may ever have
time to answer
Pedro Pascal's Mandalorian or mondo as
head of the bounty hunters guild grief
carga calls him is a walking collection
of mysteries and callbacks to older Star
Wars law
this is rifle which we see him using
early against the Beast that tries to
drag his ship in the water in chapter 1
and later to disintegrate jours and
rival bounty hunters it's the same
weapon Boba Fett is armed with during
his animated introduction in the Star
Wars Holiday Special
though we never see Fett armed with it
in the films we don't know a lot about
the Mandalorian people yet say for what
we've gathered from scenes of the
mysterious armor and other Mandalorian
survivors but the very presence of mando
foundling or not tempts us to hope we'll
get to see more of this fictional
culture and maybe some answers to some
more basic questions for instance will
we ever see Monday without as helmets so
what happens if you take that thing on
they come after you and kill you no you
just can't ever put it back on again
plot wise the goggled long-snouted
character who calls him under lorry on a
ride early in chapter 1 doesn't do all
that much
he calls mando a droid driven speeder
mando passes on the droid and the alien
calls him another speeder that's
literally falling a pass and driven by
famous funny nerd Brian Posehn but the
goggled flutist has more meaning not
only as far as Star Wars lore is
concerned but the ancient narrative
roots the Mandalorian is tapping into
more involve Star Wars fans will
recognize the flutists as an alien
quarter cuba's it's a coupe as in a new
hope who stalks the heroes around in Mos
Eisley and turns them into the Imperial
Stormtroopers but he's more than just an
easter egg when discussing the advice
George Lucas gave him Mandalorian crater
Jon Favreau revealed that Lucas reminded
him to think about ancient stories of
heroism
Lucas was heavily influenced by the
writing of Joseph Campbell whose book
the hero with a thousand faces breaks
down the commonalities among heroic
tales and different cultures in light of
this the flutist cuba's seems like a
clear reflection of Lucas's advice as
the scene is reminiscent of the myth of
the River Styx in ancient
Greek myth Styx was a river crossed by
the newly dead by way of the ferryman
Charon
but the passage cost a coin like the one
mondo tosses to the kuvasz a koopa
sniper later appears in chapter 4
attempting to assassinate baby Yoda
which regardless as to whether this is
the same cube as flutist or nuts further
reinforces the whole Kubas as an agent
of death idea
that's some pretty literary stuff Avro
there were a couple of interesting
things going on with the client the cold
Imperial who hires a Mandalorian to
bring him the assets and tui acts was
such a brimming undertone of threat when
mando deaths are asked him what will
happen to the asset once he has it for
starters there's a surprising but
perfect casting choice a Verna Hertzog
while Hertzog has acted before he's best
known as an acclaimed director of
existential our films and thinkI
documentaries even setting aside the
casting choice the client tells us a lot
about the post-imperial Star Wars world
while at the same time leading to some
interesting questions
the client is presumably someone who
wielded a good deal of power and the
Empire before its fall in spite of the
Empire's defeat in Return of the Jedi
the clients have significant resources
and influence at least enough to operate
without too much concern he's managed to
keep a loyal band of stormtroopers by
his side as well as some kind of
intelligence network clearly the Empire
is not as dead as a Death Star if cui or
the alien farmer in the Mandalorians
first two chapters who helps mando find
the assets and get back home looks
familiar to you there are a few reasons
why that might be the case sure it could
be because you recognize the facial
similarities to nick nolte
who voices the elderly farmer but it
might also be that you remember one of
the diminutive races we meet in 1980s
The Empire Strikes Back quill is an OGG
not a race scene investments floating
Cloud City they're the guys working the
machines when han Solo is frozen in
carbonite and they're the ones playing
catcher of c-3po s golden head when two
backers saves it and the rest of the
droid from being scrapped when the
Mandalorian offers queal a place on
board his ship at the end of chapter 2
the farmer tells the bounty hunter that
he is honoured but that he longer worked
to free himself from the labor of others
could it be that queer was one of the
workers we see in Cloud City it's
possible we have spoken
baby Yoda can you believe it it's too
freakin cute
stop touching things
chapter one of the mandalorian ends with
a huge reveal that the assets mandos
targets and apparently the target of
every single member of the bounty
hunters guild is an infant member of
whatever species too late Jedi Master
Yoda hails from we're not being lazy
here
no one knows much about Yoda species and
George Lucas kept it and named on
purpose but the baby's presence of
mando's affection for it has some huge
implications for the Star Wars Methos
for one thing the way the infant saves
mando from the horned beasts in Chapter
2 tells us Yoda species is even more
attuned with the force than we ever
imagined it's age leads us to a lot of
questions at 50 years old baby Yoda
would have been alive during the era of
the prequel films could it be that it
was hidden just before the Empire came
to power did Yoda know about the baby
not to mention who was guarding baby
odor in the first place who was paying
for all the men that the Mandalorian and
I g11 had to kill to get to it and more
importantly why were they guarding it in
chapter 4 we meet Kara dune a former
shock trooper for the rebellion Monto
takes note of Kara as soon as he arrives
on saw gun whirring she's there to kill
him and take baby Yoda to whatever
horrific fate the last remnants of the
Empire have in store for him
kara notices mando to making similar
assumptions about him and the -
mercenaries enjoy a fairly brutal melee
before making peace and throwing back
some soup together
[Applause]
well soup after their fight kara tells
mundo she became a mercenary after the
fall of the Empire she describes being
relegated to duty she couldn't stomach
like protecting delegates and
suppressing riots once her role the
shock trooper was over at which point
she became a gun for hire we don't know
a lot of details about Kara's character
yet but what little we know and what we
see from her tells us a lot more than
anything we know kara has a strong moral
compass Kara's the first mercenary kara
Toby meets who we know for sure harbours
loyalties to the rebellion as much as
she expresses doubts that she refuses to
abandon the farming village and even
saves baby Yoda's life the fact that she
assumed mando had a fob on her meaning
she's on the outs of the guild perhaps
like mondo Kara chose conscience over
duty and that's what has her in hiding
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bowel so you don't miss a single one
[Music]